I said don't touch my [ __ ] you're a  woman  god dammit be one you have new foster  family whatever who's my dad get out and  stay with him you don't see me working  why didn't you come fine I've been busy  we talked about this more he's not your  legal guardian anymore  I've told you that can arise coming from  rest compact is if you so nosy  never know girls less than the boys -  I'm CBS oh no she got [ __ ] up your mom  pass they would had to do my hand  towards makes you get a scholarship  listen you'll be a legend and not just  in some high school yearbook watch these  girls no okay listen up you guys  remember there's no such thing as losing  there's only winning and learning shake  hands  tell me what's going on with your father  but we have this team myself as your  social worker if I can't trust you I  can't help you  are you doing them oh now you're gonna  sink a swim  [Music]  you  you